you're welcome to this video playing am
going again one of the opponent's that I
played many many times we got an old
Indian Kings Indian now type of position
yeah same kind of setup yeah allowing
before it's a big mistake of course just
giving me tempe
yeah play c5 next oh let's say quickly
Nexus bit to wake to make an expression
I can also take with the power not quite
sure there's also not bad Jeff
and
yeah he probably intends to take here
and go night at four
hmm yeah not a phone
yeah let's it's better for black then
than I originally thought even this
allowing before Matt it's bad but it's
not it's not fatal the idea of this move
is to have the ship see form
hmm
yeah maybe I should just prevent night
f4 it's such an annoying move
hmm
is playing this very good very well I
mean
it's a very tough tough defense IAM
I hope that this position is resilient
enough the problem of all this is if
they get the bishop in my position like
on g 5o it's it gets really ugly
yeah just text at xe5
95 comes with the temple I hope this was
good i think it might be very good it
was the only move probably and but maybe
it was also good maybe pawn to d5 is
good now adequately rookie singing
nonsense of course the rookie singing
first
threatening Knight f6 with the mate
night c7a this is this right taking the
rook he takes rook takes get to check
their
if eight
night c 70 this has something better
yeah I hope it's enough I don't really
add cannot cannot cake later to tell the
end I'm also threatening 96 this is
important plus the look of course but on
Brooke young champion check
check now this is my check mate King
edge hug I wasn't so sure about King
edge five at least I didn't find didn't
find an instant made I just hoped there
is something yeah there is something
Queen everyone but if I've if I would
have found that move I don't know Queen
f 1 i'm not even sure what this is
exactly threatening our queen a Sri it's
nice to win as well it is check and no H
form check because this winter smell
this is probably what I would have
played and then try to find something
here check yeah what is winning is here
this H from each form check and then
there's no way to prevent it yeah I
don't know maybe I would have found it
not not sure but he am he I think I was
I was outplayed not sure how bad it was
but the comp just likes white red I
thought I was in trouble here g3 was
probably not good maybe am it it wasn't
so terrible rook aah seems to be much
better here queen bee to was also good
ok and now night see semanas winning
yeah then it wasn't such a bad game I
had to really had my doubts around here
thought I was a bit out plate but the
comp doesn't doesn't find so much may he
should take and now try to improve
I'm not sure how but maybe Bishop f64
Bishop g5 hmm check hmm yeah the
computer is really unimpressed it says
that 9 p-5 coming is very good very
weird I was thought that black would be
in good shape here maybe the bishop is
just pretty on default by doing doing
not much captain Anna Kournikova Bishop
looks good but never wins alright thanks
for watching